bonsoir merci de travers en direct avec
nous sur rt france malgré cette perte de
bénéfices saudi aramco ne semble pas
s'inquiéter outre mesure
comment est-ce que cela se passe-t-il du
côté des autres géants pétroliers
mondiaux
effectivement on a on a une différence
entre aramco et les autres entreprises
du même secteur énergétique donc ce qui
fait que si je compare les chiffres par
exemple de bénéfices d'aramco par
rapport aux chiffres de bp de celle de
total d'exxon mobil
on trouve que toutes les entreprises
pétrolières sont réalisées des pertes
énormes pendant le deuxième trimestre de
l'année 2000 2020 par contre à
rembourser la seule qui a pu le faire à
un bénéfice effectivement c'est pas
comparable par rapport à ce qui était le
cas l'année dernière il faut juste
rappeler corps aramco a fait un bénéfice
net l'année 2010 9 211 milliards de
dollars c'était l'entreprise qui a fait
le résultat net le plus élevé dans le
monde ça dépasse largement le bénéfice
net de facebook d'apple et de google
réunit donc cette année effectivement le
deuxième trimestre de l'année 2020 était
très très difficile pour les entreprises
pétrolières pour deux raisons d'abord le
confinement dans environ 150 pays et
donc la chute de consommation du pétrole
et effectivement il ya aussi un autre
élément essentiel c'est l élément lié à
la question de le bras de fer de
l'opecst contre principalement la russie
et l'arabie saoudite sur les prix du
pétrole
il faut juste au rap n'est que par
rapport à ramecourt cette performance
normal on élit dû à la question des
coûts c'est à dire que l a la
possibilité à faire un coût de 8 à 9
dollars pour le baril c'est pas le cas
pour les autres entreprises pétrolières
mais avec tout ça il faut également
signaler que les revenus de l'arabie
saoudite cette année du pétrole ne
seront pas comme les revenus des des
aléas dernière surtout au niveau de
budget annuel de royaumes là où
royaume a prévu un budget c'est-à-dire
basiques sur 55 à peu près 55 $ pour le
pour le baril c'est pas le cas pour
l'année 2020
alors qu'en est il des producteurs de
pétrole de schiste américain de sables
bitumeux canadiens aux états unis la
complexité c'est pas seulement la
question des déprimés ya aussi à on va
dire une guerre entre deux grands lobbys
dont le secteur du pétrole c'est à dire
ceux qui veulent garder le pétrole comme
étant la principale source énergétique
je parle par exemple de revoilà et
toutes les entreprises qui en ont
soutenu en satin un certain moment
l'administration tremblay le président
entrant pas devenir président il faut en
parler par exemple de rester là sans kit
à certains moments ministre des affaires
étrangers et qui était un ancien tueur
au final 2-2 d'exxon d'exxon mobil et
des autres entreprises qui normalement
soutenue par d'autres banques je parle
par exemple de rothschild et compagnie
qu'il voulait en quelque sorte tourner
la page du pétrole est passé ou aux
énergies renouvelables là normalement
cette guerre continue ou aux états unis
et je crois que ça dépend aussi des
élections américaines en novembre
prochain pour savoir
effectivement le futur on va dire du
secteur pétrolier pas seulement aux
états unis mais également dans le monde
du fait que en termes de marchés
financiers c'est-à-dire au niveau des
hauts niveaux de la books les
entreprises pétrolières américain sans
un grand poids dans la fluctuation des
actions boursières
que se passe t-il aussi du côté de
l'industrie qui dépend du pétrole les
producteurs de plastique par exemple
est-ce qu'ils sont aussi impactés tout à
fait là l'impact est direct sur d'autres
industries et pas seulement comme
plastique mais pas mal d'industries y
compris dans les pays dans les pays
pétroliers l'arabie saoudite même a eu
un impact dans d'autres dans d'autres
entreprises
mais je crois que avec une reprise
économique à partir de l'année 2000 21
et il peut avoir une amélioration
au niveau du rendement de ce genre
d'entreprise surtout qu'on peut avoir
plus de demandes sur la question de la
consommation
comparé à l'année à la nier 2020 on a
déjà constaté une différence entre le
deuxième trimestre et le 3ème trimestre
de l'année 2020 c'est à dire que après
le déconfinement le taux ou le prix de
baril a beaucoup augmenté la semaine
dernière et la même avoisiner 45 dollar
pour le pour le baril et ça c'est un
indicateur au vert c'est un très bon
indicateur pour ce genre d'entreprise
sachant bien qu'il faut rappeler que
pour les ont les états ou les pays qui
est pétroliers il faut déjà penser à la
question de la diversification
économique c'est à dire que l'arabie
saoudite par exemple a déjà planifié une
vision qui s'appelle vision 2030 afin de
diversifier ses ressources pétrolières
surtout de profiter de ses ressources
'le d année dernière afin d'investir
dans les grandes entreprises
et pour cette raison on a vu que le
fonds souverain saoudien le mois dernier
à acheter des parts dans facebook
hubert à apple et d'autres entreprises
c'est dans cette stratégie de
diversifier les ressources financières
de l'état
merci et pour votre analyse younes belle
félin économiste et spécialiste du monde
arabe